la police française bac les réseaux
islamistes
douze personnes interpellées aujourd'hui
à paris et en banlieue
les jeunes qui touchent le rmi sont des
plus en plus nombreux et de plus en plus
diplômés santé alimentation et cancer un
rapport prouve qu'il existe des aliments
tu protèges de cette terrible maladie
cinéma un film sur picasso et les femmes
survive in picasso avec dans le rôle du
peintre anthony hopkins
madame monsieur bonsoir une semaine très
exactement après l'explosion d'une bombe
dans une rame du rer à la station port
royal à paris
les enquêteurs poursuivent leur travail
de fourmi pour tenter de retrouver le
moindre indice aujourd'hui par exemple
des policiers ont emprunté la ligne b du
rer
à l'heure où s'est produit l'attentât la
semaine dernière dans les wagons ils ont
cherché à interroger les habitués de la
ligue maryse burgot dida les hommes en
civil sur les quais du rer b sont des
enquêteurs de la brigade criminelle
plusieurs dizaines de policiers répartis
sur l'ensemble de la ligne
c'était ce soir entre 17h45 et 18h05
mais jour tout juste après l'explosion
de la station port royal des enquêteurs
à la recherche du moindre témoignage qui
permettrait de donner des indices sur
les poseurs de la bonbonne de gaz non
seulement si on avez
suspecte
mesures
c'est ce qu'il convient d'appeler un
travail de fourmi ce passage est comme
beaucoup d'autres dit n'avoir rien
remarqué de particulier
il est vrai que lors des emmys un quant
à ce genre d' enquête de proximité
n'avait pas apporté d'élément probant
je cherchais pas au torchis de voir
aussi remis le frein
si tu étais moi quand
à 18h05 ce soir l'opération était
terminée
nous saurons dans les prochains jours si
par exemple elle a contribué à affiner
un éventuel portrait robot ce matin à
paris et dans la région parisienne une
vaste opération de police a abouti à
l'interpellation d'une douzaine de
personnes dans les milieux islamistes de
la capitale un coup de filet qui n'est
pas directement en rapport avec
l'attentât du rer mais qui s'inscrit
dans le cadre d'une traque beaucoup plus
globale des réseaux du groupe islamique
armé en europe
à cet égard nous avons très récemment
rencontré à bruxelles où il est en
résidence surveillée
ahmed zaoui un algérien considéré par
plusieurs services de police européens
comme l'un des principaux responsables
islamistes en europe reportage
thierry thuillier raymond chaplin
l'opération était prévue bien avant
l'attentât de mardi dernier
un coup de filet au but et en apparence
bien maigre aucune armée aucun document
dont étaient six
qui est dans la fourmilière aurait pour
objectif de recueillir des informations
sur les réseaux islamistes en or ces
interpellations trouvent leur origine en
belgique début 95 dans cet appartement
de bruxelles outre des armes les
policiers belges saisissent des
documents sur lesquels figurent les noms
des personnes interrogées aujourd'hui
par la police française
une dizaine d'islamistes sont aussi
arrêtées dont leur chef présumé ahmed
house condamné à quatre ans de prison
avec sursis pour association de
malfaiteurs nous l'avons rencontré il ya
quelques jours à sa sortie de prison
car malgré le sursis la belgique l'a
placé pendant un an en détention
administrative
il est aujourd'hui assigné à résidence
dans un quartier de bruxelles
expulsables s'il ne trouve pas
rapidement un pays d'accueil
présenté par les français comme un
membre actif de la mouvance islamiste
armée
il se défend de toute appartenance ou
gier
c'est le début je n'ai jamais été membre
du gia et je n'ai jamais proclamé
appartenir au jir la résistance en
réalité est légitime mais seulement une
résistance organisée juridiquement et
normalement c'est la première chose je
suis contre toute activité aveugle sans
capacité politique là c'est clair pour
moi et mes compatriotes du fils je pense
que le transfert de nos histoires et
résistante d'algérie en france comme
dans tout autre pays occidental et
confère à nos passions et ce n'est pas
dans notre intérêt que dire alors du
communiqué du gia adressée aux autorités
belges
ils exigent la libération d'ahmed zaoui
c'est un faux rétorque l'intéressé
côté belge en tout cas on ne croit pas
qu'il y ait un lien entre ahmed zaoui
les attentats en france
personnalité du fils il est considéré
comme une tête politique qu'opérationnel
un homme pour qui l' usage de la force
peut être légitime mais à l'intérieur
des frontières algériennes à noter
encore que demain matin l'un des juges
anti terroriste jean louis bruguière
partira pour l'italie pour y interroger
djamel lounici considéré lui aussi comme
le responsable des réseaux logistiques
de transport d'armes pour les maquis
algérien actuellement
série à naples à paris se poursuit le
procès du réseau de jeunes gens
d'origine algérienne et marocaine
impliqués de près ou de loin dans une
opération de déstabilisation du régime
marocain qui s'était traduit par le
meurtre de deux touristes espagnols à
marrakech en 1994 au deuxième jour du
procès on en sait un peu plus sur le
travail de recrutement des jeunes des
banlieues par les responsables des
réseaux terroristes islamistes en direct
tiré kurt et thierry plus le procès
avance en fait daniel et mieux on
comprend le fonctionnement de ce soutien
à groupe de réseaux terroristes et en
fait on découvre un amateurisme tout à
fait étonnant les commandes ont envoyé
au maroc par exemple en fait n'avait ni
véritable plan de repli ni objectifs
très précis on avait le choix soit tiré
sur des policiers ou des touristes soit
faire un braquage d'hier à tafalla
l'entraînement en france et est
également des plus sommaires marche en
montagne cours de théologie tiré au
pistolet une fois quelques heures tout
de même passé plusieurs mois en
afghanistan
là aussi sans que l'entraînement soit
véritablement plus poussée en revanche
les recruteurs du réseau eux n'étaient
pas des amateurs
leur cible leurs proies de jeunes
musulmans des banlieues désoeuvrés qui
avait déjà fait eu un premier pas vers
la religion
d'abord quelques soirées vidéo ensuite
quelques cours de religion ce sont deux
hommes qui vont recruter l'ensemble du
réseau
tarek fatah était sous leur influence il
dira devant le tribunal je pensais bien
faire j'avais une caution religieuse je
n'aurais jamais fait ça pour l'argent
si l'un des deux hommes est en fuite
l'autre est dans le box des accusés
abdelilah diane n'a pas encore parlé en
fait tout le désigne comme le principal
responsable
merci thierry le président de la
république jacques chirac s'est exprimé
aujourd'hui à propos de la situation en
france après l'attentât du rer de la
semaine dernière et il est revenu une
nouvelle fois sur l'attitude des
français face au terrorisme jacques
chirac
la france vient à nouveau d'être frappés
par le terrorisme
c'est en fait la démocratie qui vide qui
est visé les français n'en doutons pas
seront de une fois encore preuve de
sang-froid de courage et de solidarité
mais je sais
aussi qu'ils se garderont de tout
amalgame
nous ne ferons pas le jeu du terrorisme
d'aucune manière le tunnel sous la
manche trois semaines après l'accident
le trafic reprend peu à peu
après les trains eurostar la semaine
dernière ce matin reprise du trafic des
navettes voitures dans le même temps
l'enquète sur les raisons de l'accident
se poursuit admob dominique maes la
reprise du trafic les dirigeants
d'eurotunnel l'attendait depuis trois
semaines ce matin pour la première
navette tout était prêt seul manquait
les passagers à l'embarquement quelques
voitures seulement une reprise
progressive pour l'instant à peine une
navette sur deux visiblement une journée
sans problème même les passagers
semblent détendus que c'était un sens
des phenom ans est grave
on n'a pas pour ça ne va pas changer vos
habitudes
non non non ceci c'est le plus fâché le
plus beau soleil à des avions toutes ont
bien désactivante voiture et a passé
dans les ports donc une raison
franchement nous sommes parfaitement
en apparence rien de changé pourtant la
vitesse a été réduite le temps de
trajets rallongés de 15 minutes
la sécurité renforcée pendant toute la
durée des travaux une navette sera en
attente prête à partir de chaque côté et
l'équipe de pompiers sera en permanence
près du lieu de l'incident est prête à
intervenir si besoin était au même
moment les deux côtés de la manche
l'enquêté se poursuit elles s'annoncent
longues et difficiles
accident acte de malveillance côté
français
aucune hypothèse n'est privilégiée les
journaux anglais évoque quant à lui un
acte de malveillance
certains accusent même le personnel
d'eurotunnel d'être à l'origine de
l'incendié
des informations formellement démenties
par les autorités judiciaires françaises
elles parlent de tentatives de
manipulation qui vise d intérêt
économique d'eurotunnel en france
économie la privatisation de thomson les
français pourrait être fixé dès jeudi
sur la nouvelle stratégie du
gouvernement l'entreprise pourrait être
cédé en deux temps d'abord les
industries de défense
ensuite le secteur multimédia et coréens
de daewoo ne sont pas écartées de
l'offre mais leurs chances apparaît tout
de même bien réduite c'est sans doute
pour cette raison que le président du
secteur audiovisuel de l'entreprise
coréenne est arrivé aujourd'hui à paris
pour consulter tous azimuts jean-paul
chapelle berlin puisque le docteur b a
réuni l'état-major 2d ou pour préparer
sa riposte
ici à paris mais coréens sont furieux
contre la commission de privatisation
qui les a mis en cause une colère masqué
derrière un sourire de façade
j'ai lu le rapport de la commission de
privatisation plusieurs fois
c'est eux et je ne comprends toujours
pas comment un tel rapport a pu être
écrit par une autorité responsable
le candidat rival alcatel n'a même pas
mentionné l'emploi dans son offre
on s'est engagé pour créer des emplois
et notre engagement se retourne contre
nous dans la compétition c'est injuste
c'est une discrimination
si thomson est vendu en deux parties est
ce que vous êtes toujours candidat si on
complique le processus
ce sera du temps perdu thomson
multimédia va rester dans le flou et
continuera à perdre de l'argent
la valeur de l'entreprise va diminuer
encore cela va mettre en péril la survie
même de l'entreprise
un patient le dr b voudrait connaître
enfin les nouvelles modalités en
attendant aucun traitement de faveur
pour des ou b n'est plus le sauveur de
thomson multimédia il fait la queue au
restaurant comme tout le monde et pour
préserver la moindre chance de
l'emporter encore le pdg s'efforce de
rester diplomate
les débats en france sont très
passionnés il y a des points de vue très
différents mais le peuple français est
sage et finit toujours par prendre une
sage décision d où veut croire encore
qu'une sage décision lui sera favorable
ce soir au ministère de l'économie
le docteur b plaide sa cause une
dernière fois mais il prévient s'il est
définitivement écartée des eaux
réclamera au gouvernement des
explications pour le préjudice subi
en bref le blocus des ports corses par
les patrons pêcheurs élevé ce soir la
négociation aboutit les pêcheurs voulait
être incluse dans le projet de zone
franche il pourrait à la place recevoir
une aide spécifique toulouse 8e jour de
grève dans les transports en commun la
négociation également abouti la reprise
du travail a été votée un accord est
intervenu sur la réduction du temps de
travail
les bénéficiaires du revenu minimum
d'insertion rmi sont de plus en plus
jeunes et ce qui est nouveau
de plus en plus diplômés sur près d'un
million de bénéficiaires
les jeunes de moins de 30 ans
représentent 43 % des allocataires
jacques devaux gabriel camille
célibataires jeunes il a 28 ans jean
claude est presque le portrait type de
la locataire du rmi en fait c'est sa
difficulté à trouver un emploi stable
qui l'a conduit à toucher cette
allocation petits boulots petites
formations son bep en commerce était
jugée à chaque fois insuffisant par les
employeurs bon moi c'était vraiment une
barrière ne pas avoir ne pas avoir fait
des études quoi j'étais tout le temps
confrontés à des portes à des barrières
et c'est que maintenant je peux franchir
car pour jean claude le rmi et d'un
nouvel espoir cela lui permet de
bénéficier d'une formation gratuite
il suit des cours au greta et prépare le
dea a eu
l'équivalence du bac grâce à des crs et
l'aide des parents l'aspect alimentaire
du rmi et secondaire je me suis dit
pendant un moment que le rmi c'est un
échec et puis après j'ai essayé de voir
le côté positif et c'est là que j'ai
compris que grâce aux amish pourrait
justement payer les études
l'enquète du credoc montre que la
situation de jean claude se rencontrent
souvent 40% des rmistes ont moins de 30
ans ce n'est pas la misère qui les a
conduits à percevoir le rmi mais le mal
à trouver un emploi star les juges de la
réunion ont condamné aujourd'hui
l'ancien maire de saint denis de la
réunion ancien maire socialiste gilbert
annette à 30 mois de prison dont 18
ferme pour corruption monsieur annette
est impliqué dans différentes affaires
de financement politique par des
entreprises dans le cadre de passations
de marchés publics plusieurs
responsables de la compagnie générale
des eaux ont également été condamnés à
la prison avec sursis ainsi que louis
nicollin connu dans les milieux sportifs
comme président du football club de
montpellier et qui dirige une entreprise
de ramassage d'ordures ménagères
le canard enchaîné à paraître demain
révèle que le président du conseil
général de l'essonne et xavier dugoin à
négocier directement avec jean tiberi le
montant du contrat pour le rapport
réalisé par sa femme xavière tiberi
michel vaujour le roi de l'évasion
devant les assises de versa et souvenez
vous de sa spectaculaire cavale de la
prison de lhassa
c'était en 86 enlevé par sa femme aux
commandes d'un hélicoptère mais la
chance ne fut pas longtemps rendez-vous
repris il tenta par deux fois de
s'évader en 93 ya 45 ans michel vaujour
risque bel et bien de finir sa vie
derrière les barreaux
valérie ermite l'ukba chauffe à chaque
transfert de michel vaujour c'est le
même déploiement de force et pour la
même raison la psychose de l'évasion en
13 ans michel vaujour va réussir cinq
évasions dont la dernière il a
définitivement rendu célèbre le 26 mai
1986 un hélicoptère survole paris puis
la prison de la santé à l'aide de cordes
deux hommes se hisse sur le toit seul
michel vaujour réussi à s'évader
le pilote de l'hélicoptère s'appelle
nadine c'est sa femme en 1993 l'histoire
bégaye vos jours est à nouveau incarcéré
trois complices tente de le faire évader
l'un de ses complices est à nouveau une
femme elle ne s'appelle plus nadine mais
djamila c'est une visiteuse de prison
qui va follement tombée amoureuse de j
c'est vrai qu'il ya toujours les mêmes
sentiments autour des évasions de michel
aux gens de venir c'est à dire de
l'amitié c'est à dire de la région et
pour certains labos dureront toute la
lecture de l'acte d'accusation
bonjour qui a 45 ans a déjà fait 21 ans
de prison n'a cessé de regarder fixement
le plafond comme épuisée d'entendre à
nouveau sa vie défiler dans un prétoire
comme désespérée de savoir qu'il encourt
aujourd'hui 30 ans de réclusion
criminelle
en plus des 17 ans qui lui restent
encore à faire à montpellier au procès
des trois assassins de jacques roseau
ancien porte parole du recours
associations de rapatriés d'algérie
les défenseurs des accusés ne sont plus
d'accord sur la tactique à suivre pour
la défense de leurs clients sur place
elle est au lamberton
un retard étonnant ce matin à 8h30
tout le monde est là pour ce deuxième
jour de procès sauf les avocats des
accusés
ils ne sont pas loin à l'écart de la
salle d'audience ils ont une franche
explication les au bout d'une heure la
défense se vole en éclats chacun veut
voir dans ce procès et peu importe ce
qui arrivera à lausanne au loup à
navarro lui il perd son procès la partie
civile mais aucun procès politique et
certaines parties de la dépense veut le
faire le procès du creusot moi je
n'aurai plus à l'un et à l'autre avant
de faire le procès des trois accusés
certains avocats voulaient faire celui
de la victime jacques roseau mais devant
l'hostilité de ses confrères l'avocat de
jean claude lausanne ots déclare qu'il
renonce à défendre son client
je n'y comprends plus rien lâche un
lausanne ots abasourdi alors que son
avocat quitter la salle d'audience
ce que je veux expliquer c'est là le
désaveu aux roseaux qui a entraîné par
la communauté pied noir qui a entraîné
la présence ces trois garçons sur place
quand ils ont huit cents rester pour lui
demander des explications et
éventuellement les administrer une
correction
les choses ont mal tourné mais
l'essentiel c'est le désaveu de la
commune pour nous
moi c'était le désaveu de la communauté
pied noir qui a peut être mal compris le
comportement des oiseaux mais qu'il a
quand même désavoué et je peux plus
plaidé malgré les incidents les éclats
de voix après deux jours d'audience la
question essentielle reste toujours sans
réponse qui a tué jacques roseau et
c'est peut-être demain alors que seront
abordés uniquement les faits que le
procès pourrait connaître une avancée
décisive aux états unis cinq mois après
l'attentât d'atlanta qui avait fait deux
morts et une centaine de blessés pendant
les jeux olympiques l'arrestation par
erreur ensuite d'un garde du parc et
bien le fbi offre deux millions et demi
de francs aujourd'hui pour toute
information susceptible de conduire
cette fois ci à l'arrestation du ou des
vrais coupables les policiers américains
ont même rendu public l'appel
téléphonique de l'auteur de l'attentât
quelques minutes avant l'explosion de la
bombe on les coupe
l'actualité internationale maintenant
les nations unies ayant donné leur feu
vert pour les changes pétrole nourriture
l'irak a repris aujourd'hui ses
exportations de pétrole qui devrait lui
permettre de s'approvisionner en
produits de première nécessité pour une
population qui manque de tout coup
presse ont eu le seul avis le président
vis de ces riches ne cède pas il
confirme l'annulation dé victoire de
l'opposition aux élections municipales
alors que les seize pays membres de
l'otan lui demande de revenir
solennellement sur cette décision
les manifestations quand elles se
poursuivent à belgrade et demain les
syndicats ouvriers ont décidé de se
mêler aux mouvements de protestation ce
sera un test important
il n'y a pas que dans la capitale que
les défilés se suivent exemple dans une
grande ville industrielle à 150 km au
sud est de belgrade une municipalité
gagné par l'opposition eric lemasson
philippe deslandes lusine zastava était
autrefois la fierté de la yougoslavie
métallurgie armement automobile ses
cheminées nourrissait toute la ville de
kragujevac aujourd'hui tout va mal
seules les armes se vante encore le
reste de la production est un désastre
en ce moment la chaîne d'assemblage
automobile et même arrêter deux cent
mille yugo sortait pourtant chaque année
des ateliers 7000 seulement l'an passé
et cette année - encore
alors évidemment à l'heure de la sortie
du boulot les mines sont loin d'être
réjouir oui par rapport à il ya un an il
y à 80% de rouleaux ambre
il y a un peu de boulot mais vraiment
très peu il y en a beaucoup qui sont en
congés payés et les salaires comment ça
se passe il n'y a pas de salaire on ne
touche pas toujours pas depuis le mois
d'octobre
on n'a pas une hausse à l'aise quarante
mille ouvriers dont la moitié en congés
payés c'est le nom local du chômage
technique salaires 500 francs par mois
autant dire que cette vitrine en passe
de lusine n'attire pas les regards la
moins chère des you go coûte 30 mille
francs
en arrivant à kragujevac on s'attend à
voir s'exprimer la colère ouvrière dans
les manifestations effectivement comme à
belgrade l'opposition rassemble ici
chaque jour tous les mécontents de la
ville mais les ouvriers n'y sont pas
vous avez 80 ou 90 % des ouvriers qui ne
travaillent pas ils ont déjà dû faire
face à cinq ou six ans de guerre et de
crise pendant lesquelles ils ont été
obligés de se débrouiller de cultiver
leur jardin de faire des trafics
tout ce qu'on appelle l'économie grise
c'est humain ils ont perdu la motivation
pour un combat ouvrier et un combat de
classe c'est la grande force du
président milosevic lui qui a toujours
su rallier les cernes sous sa bannière
nationalistes comptent encore sur la
docilité de ce monde rural et ouvriers à
kragujevac l'opposition a gagné les
municipales
le futur maire à temps de son mandat de
pouvoir enfin contrôler les médias
locaux
un appel à la grève générale est lancée
l'enjeu pour les antilles milosevic sera
de faire prendre la grève contestataires
jusqu'au coeur des ateliers de l'usiné
stava à kragujevac en belgique nouveau
scandale au sein du gouvernement le
ministre régional de l'éducation de
wallonie soupçonnaient de pédophilie a
préféré démissionner alors que le
parlement wallon ne s'est pas encore
prononcé sur son dossier de son côté la
cour de cassation demande un délai pour
statuer sur le sort du vice-premier
ministre belge elio di rupo lui aussi
accusé vous savez de pédophile retour en
france sur le front des inondations dans
le sud la tendance générale est à la
décrue heureusement aujourd'hui
notamment de l'eau
a narbonne et aux alentours où tout de
même l'alimentation en eau potable n'a
toujours pas été rétablis patrice randle
frédéric faure la décrue 2 cm par heure
aujourd'hui à narbonne et déjà les
premières conclusions dans une situation
qui si lisa sion quand même qui est
assez pénible et prévisible certes les
inondations sont d'abord dus aux pluies
torrentielles
mais il ya autre chose par le passé
l'homme a voulu se mêler de la vie de la
nature en laquelle c'est bien connu ne
manque pas une occasion de se venger
tout a commencé ici à coursan à 20 km de
la mer il y a un peu plus de 2 765
inondations catastrophiques 60,6 et
senior des états mais si de charger le
tour de l'aude ils fondés ni la course à
l'ours deux par deux pour sa ligne
droite à la mer quatre ans plus tard
inondations catastrophiques que les
coursannais décide de remettre une lande
d'almeida la sellerie et nous en sommes
toujours au même en rouge l'ancien lit
de l'aude qui serpentait dans la région
le fleuve naturel prenait son temps en
bleu le lit actuelle trajectoire quasi
rectiligne et en marron sur ces images
le résultat que contemple des badauds à
l'heure de la dcri que nous on a vite
que la plage on à la barre devant la
plage avec des amis qui en ont qui ne
résident pas légèrement narbonne
évidemment ils n'ont jamais vu
là cette région là qu'on ne connaît que
l'été il n'a jamais vu dans ces
conditions là alors pour épater les amis
pas question de manquer de telles photos
il est vrai que la dernière crue de
cette ampleur date de 1971 santé un
rapport réalisé par des spécialistes
français anglais américain prouve qu'il
existe un rapport entre alimentation et
cancer certains aliments protège de
cette terrible maladie
c'est le cas par exemple des fruits et
légumes jean daniel flaysakier alain
dumas vous croyez être au marché en fait
vous êtes dans un laboratoire devant vos
yeux s'étale vitamines minéraux
oligo-éléments des fibres et même des
tannes et tout cela mélangé donne les
meilleurs produits de prévention en
matière de cancer cela s'appelle des
fruits des légumes
la preuve c'est écrit dans ce rapport de
plus de 500 pages prenez l'aïe
il contient du sulfure dalil il ya des
chinois qui remontent jusqu'à 20 grammes
par jour
ils font dix fois moins de cancers de
l'estomac que leurs voisins et ses
tomates bien rondes elles contiennent du
lycopène une substance qui protège des
cancers du pancréas et de la prostate
mais en france la plupart d'entre nous
avons une alimentation qui n'est pas
franchement végétarienne certains même
sont de véritables oeuvres
pas question pour autant de rejeter la
viande rouge mais pour protéger son
côlon mieux vaut ajuster les doses de
steak
on a trouvé que pour les cancers des
voies digestives surtout pour les
cancers du côlon d alimentation en
déséquilibre est très très champion des
pauvres légumes augmente le risque de
cancer de l'intestin encore une fois
c'est une question d'équilibré
il faut donc privilégier les légumes et
fruits il faut privilégier les légumes
les fruits les céréales complètes et
avoir une alimentation qui ne soit pas
exclusivement basée sur des produits
d'origine animale
enfin n'imitez pas nos amis américains
et éviter les fortes doses de vitamines
et de bêta carotène
elles peuvent être très dangereuses
si vous rêvez de vitamine c manger des
fruits il y à 360 mg de vitamine c dans
un kiwi
oui oui brillant la république a remis
aujourd'hui à paris le prix des droits
de l'homme pour des actions entreprises
dans l'ex yougoslavie ou encore à cuba
et dans les territoires palestiniens
à cette occasion jacques chirac est
revenu sur sa volonté de sanctionner
tous les propos racistes ou xénophobes
le président la république lorsque des
attitudes ou des pratiques
discriminatoires des paroles racistes ou
xénophobes s'exprime dans notre pays
alors elles doivent être relevés
poursuivi sanctionnés nous ne laisserons
pas les appels à l'exclusion la haine à
la violence voire au meurtre s'abriter
derrière la liberté d'expression ce
discours est l'occasion pour nous de
revenir sur la notion de race récemment
souvenez-vous évoquée par jean marie le
pen et qui a provoqué toute une
polémique car effectivement le mot race
existe bien dans la constitution
française mais pas au sens où
l'entendent certains c'est le thème de
notre enquête de ce soir menée par
valérie fournis ou josé boulesteix
intitulé un mot de quatre lettres
article 2 de la constitution de 1958 la
france est une république indivisible
laïque démocratique et sociale
elle assure l'égalité devant la loi de
tous les citoyens sans distinction
d'origine de race ou de religion
ce mot race inscrits dans les fondements
même de notre société peut mettre le
doute dans les esprits car l'idée de
race humaine n'a rien de scientifique
au sortir de la guerre les pères de la
constitution voulu donner à notre nation
les garanties juridiques pour que les
génocide des juifs ne recommence pas le
glissement systématique des hommes par
as et pour les scientifiques une
aberration il préfère parler de
population
il parle de populations parce qu'ils ont
trouvé que les caractères d'une
population dans une population varie de
façon énorme et varient presque autant
d'un organe d'un individu à un autre
d'une population à une haute saison
pratiquement complètement abolie en
france est due à la mise au 19e siècle
les scientifiques parlent de race c'est
le français broca qui en avant tout
l'expression méthodiquement une classe
les hommes notamment en mesurant les
crânes il fonde l'anthropologie le
compte de gobineau également français
lui va plus loin
après une série de voyages notamment ici
en erythrée l'idée de la suprématie
d'une race sur une autre de ses nuits il
donne naissance à la notion de race
aryenne ces thèses ne sont pas
approuvées par tous les ethnologues de
l'époque tous de grands voyageurs
même si leur vision de l'espèce humaine
s'arrête également aux différences
culturelles et à la couleur de la peau
les ethnologues était un produit de la
société coloniale qui étaient convaincus
de la supériorité de l'occident sur le
reste de la planète
il se croyait donc le droit d'aller
partout de donner des ordres et
d'enregistrer les moeurs des sauvages
comme ils disaient auprès desquels ils
allaient enquêter comme s'ils savaient
étaient des êtres d'une catégorie
inférieure
ribéry mal à ces conduites des chacals
polluants si la france n'avait pas le
coeur de ne pas exécuter des individus
de votre espèce il n'y en aurait plus un
de bilan les liens entre la politique et
l'ethnologie ont longtemps été très
étroit
l'invention du quotient intellectuel par
le français alfred binet a même servi la
politique américaine en 1917 d'abord
pour mesurer l'intelligence de ces
hommes vivent et pour l'europe puis
ensuite pour sélectionner les immigrés
trop nombreux qui est insupportable
c'est de s'appuyer sur la science pour
soutenir ça car la science ne peut la
science fait la politique et vient la
chercher
la science ne soutient pas le concept de
race mais la politique vient chercher la
science pour essayer d'expliquer et de
maintenir une situation de dépendance
déjà porteuse exemple le cas georges
mi-temps bon cette technolog suisse
naturalisé français en 1946 à théoriser
son antisémitisme dans des ouvrages ce
doux scientifiques ou les nazis
maintenant il peut être
objet important de propagande quand les
nazis occupent occupe la 30e à tel point
qu'il fourni les documents nécessaires
l'exposition du juif et la france sous
vichy remarquable exposition où se
trouve rassembler les documents les
photographies et montrant le père est
juif dans tous les domaines de
l'activité nationale et tout
naturellement montandon devient le ratio
luck français auprès du commissariat
général aux questions juives
c'est lui qui délivre les certificats
d'appartenance ou de non appartenance à
la race dit julie ve
c'est ces deux expertises en verront de
nombreux français dans les camps de
concentration
le racisme érigée en système politique
aujourd'hui encore les émules existe
même si la science une autre
constitution bannit toute ségrégation
basé sur un simple mot de quatre lettres
bref manifestations de protestation hier
soir à grenoble à l'occasion d'une
réunion publique tenue par jean marie le
pen la manifestation s'est terminée en
affrontements avec la police six
personnes interpellées vont être
traduites en correctionnelle ce que l'on
appelle les intermittents du spectacle
ont manifesté un peu partout en france
aujourd'hui occupée des théâtres ils
sont en conflit avec le patronat
français le cnpf à propos de la réforme
du régime d'assurance-chômage thiriet
jacques gérault d'un opéra à l'autre de
bastia garni on les accuse souvent
d'être dans la lune mais lorsqu'il
s'agit de défendre leur statut social et
les ont les pieds sur terre
comédiens danseurs musiciens techniciens
du spectacle dans la rue pour dénoncer
l'attitude du cnpf accusé de vouloir
modifier leur assurance chômage
actuellement un intermittent du
spectacle qui travaillent 507 heures ou
une indemnisation sur 12 mois un nouveau
projet proposerait 660 16h pour une
indemnisation dégressif sur huit mois
mais ce rôle là ils n'entendent pas le
jouer pas question de devenir
intérimaire après avoir été intermittent
aux trois quarts de ceux qui sont
comédiens ne le seront plus on va les
retrouver tous ceux qui n'ont plus rien
mais c'est très dur déjà ça sent secteur
que l'on voulait vous faire plus faire
700 heures sans guerlain sur huit mois
c'est ingérable
mais le cnpf aligne deux chiffres en 95
les cotisations versées par les
intermittents représente 620 millions
pour 2 milliards 8 remis les artistes
souligne l'importance de la vie
culturelle dans un pays et avance
d'autres arguments
80% d'entre nous qui ont travaillé dix
quinze ans un instrument de musique
je suis ici donc je représente et
musiciens vont se retrouver rmistes
alors qu'on peut le devenir et rémy sans
rien faire donc on aura vraiment choisi
la voie longue
comment exiger que l'on commence la
merde mais revenu avec mozart au travail
votre profession ceux-ci décorateur le
statut actuel protège un artiste entre
deux emplois
mais quelques-uns peu nombreux n'hésite
pas en abuser
après une rencontre entre le ministre de
la culture et jean gandois les
intermittents ont obtenu quatre mois de
sursis quatre mois pour un dossier
brûlant est grave ce soir de nombreux
théâtres sont occupés et en province
comme à paris pour le spectacle ce sera
rideau
à noter que ce reportage a été monté par
un monteur lui-même en grève aujourd'hui
l'acteur gallois soeur anthony hopkins a
été fait aujourd'hui commandeur des arts
et des lettres par le président du sénat
rené monory c'était ce matin
cet après midi plus exactement au palais
du luxembourg en telium skins qui est le
héros d'un film de james ivory qui
lui-même vous l'avez vu à l'instant a
été décoré intitulé survive in picasso
qui relate le rapport du célèbre peintre
avec les femmes
anthony hopkins pour la circonstance est
une nouvelle fois parfaitement glisser
dans le rôle il ressemble à s'y
méprendre au peintre tout comme il
ressemblait à richard nixon ou encore à
hitler ou encore à winston churchill
dans d'autres films
pascal deschamps pascal pays
jean d'une idylle aussi passionné que
mouvementée elle a 23 ans quand ils se
rencontrent en 1944 et françois gillot
jeune artiste peintre de bonne famille
se laisse emporter dans un pari qui
savoure sa liberté quitte 9 par un
tourbillon nommé pablo picasso quelques
femmes des centaines de milliers de
femmes tellement maintenant il ya dix
ans d'une vie d'artiste picasso amoureux
puis qu'elle soit fidèle picasso
fantasque et tyrannique
le film est inspiré de plusieurs
témoignages recueillis dans un livre
picasso créateurs et destructeur toute
la vérité d'un homme plein de
contradictions
monsieur je suis navré tout ça c'est de
la faute mais je suis à votre service
depuis si longtemps 25 ans 50 pro monde
ça tue le alors à prévoir temps là après
tout ce que j'ai été pour vous vous me
renvoyez je vous renvoie et qu'elle
souhaitait un homme hors du commun
après tout tous ces gens qui tournait
autour de lui pouvait toujours le
quitter si ça ne leur plaisait pas il
restait c'était leur choix
on peut aussi dire que beethoven que
mozart étaient des monstres
il m'arrive souvent de faire des erreurs
et ça arrive aussi à dieu il fait un
teckel ensuite un éléphant un écureuil
une baleine comme moi il a tout essayé
comme moi il n'a aucun style le style
savent bien qu'une fois qu'on est mort
j'ai le cerveau riz n'a pas reçu le
soutien de la famille françois gillot
avait pourtant collaboré au projet avant
de sortir et sans donner d'explication
août jean l'on dit ici en france ce film
rend plutôt hommage je ne comprend pas
sa réaction
certains admirons dans ce picasso
lettres libre envers et contre tous
d'autres regretteront qu'on étale la vie
privée d'un génie pour les mettre
d'accord
ses toiles exposées au grand palais
portrait de femme aimée puis quittez une
vie de peinture une vie de sentiment
réconcilier pour l'éternité dans les
musées dans un instant la météo nathalie
rihouet dernier journal thierry
thuillier 20h50 james bond 007 l'homme
au pistolet d'or demain les 4 vérités
gérard leclerc recevra jean françois
copé député rpr 13 heures patrick chêne
quant à moi je vous retrouverai demain
soir à 20 heures je vous souhaite une
excellente soirée sur la prochaine
bonsoir